make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with another
what if story this time
answering the question what if the
immortal hulk got adamant
and as part of that i think the first
question we have to answer is how did
the hulk
come to get adamantium so the impetus of
this story is the revival of the weapons
plus program the clandestine
organization that was responsible
for the creation of a number of marvel
superheroes and villains most famously
wolverine deadpool and captain america
and what we learn is that the program
has been revived by a group who we never
see
but is only alluded to and his goal is
the creation of a living weapon
that's capable of causing as much
destruction as possible and that's all
we know about the project up front now
naturally those running the project
focus on the hulk as the best candidate
for this particular situation
as he's already the best in the world
it's smashing things and he'll be made
even better
at it by the enhancements they plan on
making now knowing that bringing the
hulk in against his will would be close
to impossible
weapons plus sends agents to abduct
bruce banner in his sleep
injecting him with a tranquilizer to
prevent him from turning into the hulk
and then killing them all before they
get him back to the facility now once
they're back they place bruce in an
induced coma while they place neural
manipulation chips in his brain so they
can control his thoughts and emotions
meaning that not only can they tell him
what to do but they can artificially
increase his anger level which will
result in the hulk getting
stronger and stronger and so bruce is
woken up and the neural chips are tested
by increasing his anger level and
triggering his transformation into the
hulk
now once bruce is in his hulk form his
handlers use the neural implants to
render him unconscious while remaining
hooked out
then they replicate the same process
they had previously used to bond
adamantium to wolverine's skeleton on
the hulk and just for good measure they
throw in some adamantium claws
as well and so at the end of the process
they deliver to this mysterious entity
that they've contracted
with a hulk with an adamantium skeleton
and claws that can be remotely
controlled so it's kind of like weapon h
except not crappy and so the next time
that we get to see the hulk he's just
absolutely demolishing a city his
teammates on the avengers come and try
to take him down and because of the
neural implants he's not responsive
to them at all he's just in an all-out
rage and getting madder by the second
now when the avengers realize that
there's no reasoning with him they try
and subdue him which is nearly
impossible under normal circumstances
but is made even more difficult as the
hulk becomes more and more enraged and
so when thor is hit by one of the hulk's
punches he remarks at how much more
painful it was than normal and
immediately the rest of the avengers
know something's not right about the
situation their assumption is validated
when the hulk pops his claws for the
first time
in battle and much of their horror one
of them ends up impaling black panther
cutting right through his vibranium suit
and
killing him now at this point the
avengers are scrambling for a new plan
right because none of them want to share
the same fate thor remains engaged in
battle with the hulk and he's able to
deal the most damage to him and can also
do so
while staying out of range of the hulk's
adamantium claws meanwhile the rest of
the avengers try and formulate a plan to
negate the hulk's recent upgrade and so
just a little bit about adamantium is
considered to be the hardest metal in
the marvel universe outside of thor's
hammer and is able to cut through
basically anything other than adamantium
and captain america's shield that's made
up of alloy adamantium and vibranium
unfortunately
none of these things are especially
helpful at this moment for the avengers
they have capped shield and thor's
hammer sure but cap shield is like two
and a half feet in diameter right so
it's not really going to offer much
protection from the hulk's massive claws
and thor's hammer is also not very big
and can only be lifted by one of them
and so the best thing they could do
would be to make some armor out of
adamantium but they don't have time for
that and it's not like they're going to
just have piles of adamantium on hand
or a way to melt it down it's a
difficult process and once adamantium
hardens it can't be melted anyway they
also don't have time to travel to asgard
and get some dwarves to force new uru
weapons so they're going to have to
basically make do with what they have
now tony stark summons his hulkbuster
armor which is exceedingly durable but
it's not going to hold up to the
immortal hulk's adamantium claws for
very long captain america does his best
to distract the hulk and let thor and
iron man land as many blows as possible
but it becomes clear that this is
ultimately an exercise in futility and
they will eventually
fall to the hulk in battle and so they
put out a call for reinforcements but
captain marvel is off world battling
some cosmic threat or something like
that who knows who cares the fantastic
four is in latvia dealing with doctor
doom now just when all seems lost
some unexpected help arrives in the form
of the x-men
lately the x-men have been singularly
focused on building the nation of
krakowa into a world power and so it
seems odd for them to show up and help
the avengers to save an american city
but here they are nonetheless now rather
than the x-men
running in as a team magneto steps
forward and lifts the hulk
off the ground and begins ripping the
adamantium out of him and we get this
crazy visual of adamantium coming
through hulk's pores as magneto stands
over him now once the adamantium is
removed
charles xavier enters the hulk's mind
and amplifies his healing factor to the
point that he's able to reject the
neural implant that weapons plus had
placed in his brain and is able to calm
the hulk down to the point that he
reverts back to being bruce banner he
then probes the whole subconscious to
find out where the weapons plus facility
is and then sends a strike team led by
wolverine to destroy it and so while in
the facility wolverine finds a document
that detailed the agreement between
weapons plus
and the mysterious benefactors to bring
the hulk in for enhancement he doesn't
recognize either of these names but
pockets the document
anyway now while it seems that
everything has been wrapped up nicely
and the whole crisis has been averted we
cut to a scene on kakoa
after everything has calmed down and the
only two people in the room where the
mutant
council usually meet are xavier and
magneto and we learn from their
conversation that the mysterious
individuals that resurrected the weapons
plus project
was none other than magneto and xavier
themselves and they had done so
to create an event that would allow the
x-men to be seen as heroes that
saved the world from the rampaging hulk
when the other heroes of the earth were
completely unable to stop him and so we
also learned that they had done this
without the approval of the council and
they had kept it from the rest of the
x-men using false names to sign
all the contracts with weapons plus and
sending a team to destroy the facility
to cover their tracks but before the
story comes to a close we see a
conversation between wolverine
jean grey and cyclops who as you may or
may not know all live together now and
so they're obviously
pretty close now wolverine pulls out the
paper with the signatures of people that
none of them have ever heard of
scott and gene look at him visibly
confused and so cyclops would ask are
these names supposed to mean something
to us and wolverine will reply no but
the sense i'm picking up from the paper
should and that's where i would end the
story with it being obvious that
wolverine knows that xavier and magneto
were involved and kept the x-men in the
dark which is
definitely going to sow the seeds of
distrust among the x-men and lead to
some big time drama
after he reveals it to his teammates but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like now we'll
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you